hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a big update on amc
i have to say that it was uh very tough
to make a good analysis in the past few
weeks there was a lot of tricks in this
market
so i worked hard i checked the price
action very carefully i checked
all the information as well about the
option market the synthetic short
interest the volumes and i think i came
up with a very strong and solid case
so let's get into it
[Music]
all right so maybe the first thing guys
i want to show you is the spreadsheet so
it's been a long time you didn't see me
showing you guys this so let's quickly
have a look
here at what we are having so this is
the option open interest all right so
here you have all the different strikes
so going from five
to 145 and i here get
all the open interest for all the
maturities all right so i go
i take the eighth uh 13th of august the
20th of august
so on and so forth until uh jan 23. i
then compute the data myself guys using
black shells formula all right so this
is this formula
you know guys i showed you this many
times and it'd be long time i didn't
have a look at this because i had some
issues with my bloomberg access but
whatever
uh now it's good and so look at what we
are having here so then i compute all
the synthetic shorts
that we're having on amc and what is
very interesting
to see here so first thing we have eight
percent of synthetic short all right
with amc at 32
we can go up to 14 here the maximum
level i
have seen in may so before the second
squeeze if i can call it like this
was 20 all right so we're not there yet
but what i saw after that was around 10
so we are building back some upside
gamma all right
this is mostly coming from here guys
from the 145 strike
look at the number of shares again that
we're having here
guys all right we're having around 16
million
uh equivalent shares all right this is
just
you know insane in terms of option
distribution
and you can see how you know just big
this number option is it's the biggest
option open interest that we're having
at the 400 strike all right this is
insane this is going to create a lot of
upside momentum if we start to go higher
with the gamma this is what we call the
gamma squeeze all right market makers
they would have no other choice than
just
buying buying and buying once we get
closer look for example if you go to 16
the synthetic uh short position
goes from 1.2 billion to
3 billion all right and it's going to be
12 of the total flood share
so it's just insane yes all right so it
means that market makers would have to
buy 2 billion usd
notional of amc just to stay covered all
right this is already using the delta
another thing that is very interesting
to see here guys and this is just fact
uh when you the delta is the primary to
finish in the money that's the
definition
and if you want to know for example what
is the probability given by market
makers
for for example amc to go 200 you just
take the 100
strike delta and you can see for example
for
september so it's column l so it's 43
guys right so there is a 43 probability
we trade
above 100 in september this is the
priority given by the market
uh because the volatility is at 215
so this volatility has dropped since
like juno
but it's still very very high guys and
you can see for example the probability
to trade i don't know
at 145 for example in gen 23
i guess it's just 63 percent all right
guys
so this is the probability given by the
market this is not
a technical analysis this is a fact then
this is just showing me that and i can
tell you guys that this is
totally unusual you don't have this kind
of option distribution on any stock any
stock guys
so this is the reason why i really
believe we're gonna have
this move up coming soon now let's go
back to technicals
and i'm gonna show you here so once
again guys i tend to beat my counting
i'm gonna explain here the for me
two maybe three different scenarios i'm
gonna try to be quick
but it's it's important to understand uh
what
is happening here so first i'm gonna
take a step back and
i just wanna point out one thing guys
you know that moves up i mean
motive waves some moves that are going
into the direction of the trend
that develop in five ways and that
usually the third wave
they like to take back some major level
here we just
went through dual time high during this
third wave so one
two three so through the 35 level
then four and you know i really believe
there's going to be this
wave for this reason because i think
that the trend is going up
right now guys all right since december
20. so if this is the case
we're gonna have this fifth wave now in
terms of levels
so i just use the ratios that are
here in the elliott wave book and
basically it's telling you that when you
have
five waves move it can go up or down
the fifth wave is a ratio of one plus
three
all right so either it's equal to 0.618
times one plus three it's here you just
divide this by 0.618
or it's equal to 1.618 times one plus
three
so here if i do this if i apply
uh this method so either here there are
two different uh countings all right
here i'm being conservative but if i'm
more aggressive
i'm gonna do a one two three four five
here and then here we're gonna have
another one
so let me stay conservative and i
measure just from here to here
and in this situation i put it to the
bottom of the force we
have the target i'm talking about for a
long time this is
still my target guys and i just showed
you the option market that for me
is a very good sign of what might happen
and i combined this with
fib extension ratios and elliot with
theory and this gives me 130.
i just want to point out the fact as
well guys that
this is exactly using this method that
here i found that we would go to you see
to the uh
so 68 is giving me here so i measure one
in this shorter term
one two three four five i measure one
plus three and the 1.618
is here you know around 70. so this is
how i found that we would go here so
using the same method we going 230
now we need to analyze even if it's
tough what is happening in this
force corrective wave that is very
tricky so i'm going to give you
three scenarios so the first one
to be honest i really don't know which
one is gonna play out so i'm just giving
you those scenarios and then
we're gonna see on the shorter term what
is happening to know
in which direction we are going my first
scenario is that we have a
b and c the only issue with this
scenario is that my a wave
so it's here there should be five
three five all right in an abc and my a
wave is not really in five waves
but fair enough the c wave is in five
waves
one two three four five and whenever we
have a one two three four five with
one two three that is complete we can
use the same technique i just showed you
twice
you measure from the beginning of the
first wave to
the end of the third wave you apply it
to the start of the fifth wave
and you came up guys with the different
ratios so either once again
this one or this one so it's 0.618 or
1.618 of 1.3 so here it brings us either
to 24.5
or to okay
i don't even see it
sorry i had an issue here let me take
this again
so from here to here um okay i don't
have the 1.618
but whatever uh you can see that uh the
only ratio
that here would make sense is the 0.618
all right so this would go to 24.4
and oh surprise how funny this is as
well the level that is given
us by the bottom of this force wave so
let me go
on a shorter time frame so just you see
when we have different methods coming
back to the same level it just gives
more weight to this
scenario and here the bottom of the
force wave is here
and usually uh false waves they'll act
so this
force wave here they like to correct to
the bottom of the force or the top of
the third of the preceding wave counting
which is here
uh 35 or 24 so this is the reason why 24
for me is a very strong level
so first scenario we go there and of
course then we strongly bounce back
guys and we go to 130 and
roughly this should be happening before
september because here we have this
trendline that is going to put that if
it's broken
is going to create some momentum on the
upside so and this trend line is
crossing the 24 level on the 15th of
september
so this is for me kind of the worst case
is that we trade at 24
on the 15th of september and then we
start to go higher
but once again like i told you guys i
don't really like this a wave that is
only in three wave
so as it was pointed very well but some
of you on my discord
uh when we discussed this by the way
very quickly guys
i reopen my discord and i put back
some more places if you want uh to join
any memberships
you can find all the information in the
description of this
video and when we were discussing this
case i had a very nice
like proposal of counting that i'm going
to show you guys here
but that is a valid counting but for me
that has one small issue
that is basically closer to this not abc
but wxy and we often have wxy's
correction
right now all right so instead of five
three five we have
three three three and what i saw was
something like this w
x y and i checked this very carefully
because this is a valid counting
but the only issue had is that as you
can see the w
wave should roughly be equal to the y
wave or
at least 0.618 and in this situation the
w
the y wave is to me too short all right
because when i measure w
i apply it to the top of the x wave you
know it should go
if this counting is correct you know to
4
or 2 20. so to me this is not working
well and i would rather do
so i don't really like discounting but
what is good about discounting
is that this collection would be over
here which is possible
but i have another counting that to me
is better is that you put w
here abc all right three waves
x here abc
and then here a b c and in this
situation
look what is good is that i measure the
w wave i applied to the bottom of the
x-wave
all right and now i come up with the
one-to-one relation
shown here one to one relation between w
and y wave is actually battling at 29
which is roughly where
once and this is a valid counting too so
i would rather
use this one all right which is similar
so basically we have two different
countings that are both valid that are
both respecting
the elliot wave and fib ratios
so it's very hard to know which one is
correct if any of those is correct we're
going to find out soon
so we need to see on the shorter term
what is happening so to do that
use the mean guys use the mean and let's
see
let's see what we have so first thing
that is for me
so sorry let me go back on the flowers
first thing is that here we're having a
bullish
uh divergence all right market making
lower lows all right clearly from the
15th of july
to the 5th of august and the macd is
going higher all right so this is
a bullish divergence it means that the
market is out of steam
so this is suggesting that discounting
might be actually the right one all
right
this is one more hint another hint that
we can use
now we zoom in is
that here guys we having this
downtrend all right as you can see
this small downtrend that is here and we
have 35 that was strong support you can
see here supported the price here as
well here resistance
here resistance again that is gonna as
well help us to know in which
uh direction we are going so if we break
this
short term downtrend here and we go into
the
green rectangle here then this would
mean
guys that so here we will have first a
very nice buying opportunity
then we would probably find some
resistance around this level
and we need to break those two levels
before confirming i mean not for sure
as you saw we had some bull traps before
but if we break this
if we do something like this it would
start to look very good to me all right
so here we're gonna have a lot of buying
opportunities as well
on the other hand if we go lower and we
follow the first scenario we
gonna have here a buying opportunity and
here another one so just
to let you know that you know there is a
plan for everything
so here what we want to see to confirm
that this counting is correct and that
this correction is complete
and once again it's following nicely the
rules you know in terms of three three
three
and one to one relation between w and y
wave
the y wave being like this just to make
it clear
them abc we need to know what is gonna
happen around this levels all right here
is gonna be the very important question
that we are having where is this market
going to go so we need to wait to see
more price action but in both cases once
again let me come back to you know
what is to me my strong case is that in
both cases we're having here
one two three four and we're gonna have
this fifth
wave that is i mean i really believe it
and
that is also we're gonna have here this
fifth wave i believe
and the option market is also showing us
something like this
is likely to happen so yes that's it for
me i hope you enjoyed this video i hope
i managed to explain
once again how i build up my views even
if it's tough in this kind of market
how i choose between each scenario which
one is more likely to happen
how i build up my scenarios respecting
elliott wave theory
fibrations all these things and if you
did enjoy this video please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys